good afternoon everyone
and welcome uh i'm stephen pitty
professor of history american studies
and ethnicity race and migration and i'm
also the director of the yale center for
the study of race indigeneity and
transnational migration
it's wonderful to see so many people
here today
with us for this exciting conversation
we're happy to host this conversation
about the first uh
english language translation of severus
poems keeping in mind of course that in
talking about this
exiled cuban author those of us in new
haven
are doing so on the historical and
contemporary homelands of many
indigenous people and nations
including the mohegan machintok at
pequot eastern pequot
scatico golden hill pakistan niantic
quinnipiac and others
our conversation today features
translator
david francis who serves as dean of
grace hopper college here at yale
university
where he also teaches in the program in
ethnicity race and migration
david's translations and poems have
appeared in inventory
the fsg book of 20th century latin
american poetry
guernica exchanges the brooklyn rail
poetry daily the chronicle of higher
education
and elsewhere professor francis holds an
mfa in poetry writing from columbia
university
and a phd in romance languages and
literatures from harvard university
he received a fulbright to translate the
poetry of colombian writer
jose asuncion silva into english
and he is currently translating a
collection of poems
by the cuban author jorge oliveira
castillo
and another by poets from northern
mexico
uh as i already mentioned about briefly
his translation of sardui's poetry
footwork just published in 2021 by
circumference books
is the first collection of the cuban
authors poems translated into english
david francis will be in conversation
today with sean mcdaniel
a terrific scholar who is currently
assistant professor
of american studies and ethnic and
ethnicity at the university of southern
california
intersecting caribbean latin american
and latinx literary and cultural studies
and
intellectual history professor
mcdaniel's research
explores race gender sexuality
aesthetics modernism and dissidence
in print visual and sonic cultures of
the americas
his first book centenary subjects
race reason and rupture in the americas
is forthcoming later this year
from vanderbilt university press
professor mcdaniel
is working on a second book entitled
cuban chic
queer deco and diasporic modernism in
new york
which examines the literary graphic
sartorial sonic
and cinematic cultures of interstitial
cubanidad in new york as well
as its inter-american routes through
havana
santiago de cuba merida veracruz
and los angeles we
in the ritm center feel very honored to
be able to host this celebration of
david francis's translation of
saturday's poems
let me thank the associate director of
yale's ritm center matthew taniko for
his hard work putting our event together
as well as center staff maggie katz and
nicole edwards
and of course a great big thanks to the
whitney humanities center
for co-sponsoring this event now let me
let me encourage all of you who are here
today uh to submit your questions
to professor francis and professor
mcdaniel uh by using the q
a function here on zoom which is a great
way to be in conversation
with them i know that they would love uh
to hear your questions about sangui
about cuban authors and other writers
about translation
and about other relevant the topics that
come up for you during the course of
this conversation so please do use the q
a function to submit
questions to them and we're really happy
to say that circumference books
uh the publisher of sandui's footwork
has offered a discount off for today's
attendees who'd be interested
in purchasing that book because i hope
all of you are
the discount code from circumference
books um for this publication
um is going to be posted in the chat
uh if you know people who'd be
interested in this event but who aren't
here today who can't make it for this
conversation
please do let them know um that this
recording will be on
the yale youtube site on our the ritm
playlist in the weeks to come and that
they can find it there
and with that i want to thank all of you
for joining us today
and i want to turn the microphone over
with great joy
uh to professor david francis and
professor sean
mcdaniel thank you thank you steve
and i'm just so elated to be here to
uh for the first public celebration of
this book
and i have so much gratitude to you to
matthew teneco
to sean mcdaniel the whitney humanities
center
and ritm for for supporting this uh this
event so thank you very much
uh i want to start with a brief
introduction
to who sargui is uh reading from the
first page of the book
and then what i'll do is uh give a sort
of panorama
of the poems that i translated from the
beginning of the work to the
to the end and that should take about 20
minutes
and then i i really can't wait to to
discuss the poems
and questions that everyone has uh about
the translations about surgery
about the book uh afterward with with
sean so
that will be coming soon
the scarred body or the image of its
absence
faced with the question of how to
translate the body of sergey's poetry
i feel a sense of stuttering how to
convey the enormity of seeming
contradiction i encountered while
translating his poems
indeed a body of work that sings on its
own
that celebrates the carnal life the
sensual experiences of dance
of painting food music and sexual
pleasure
but that also recognizes in these
pleasures the imminence of one's passing
his 56 years of life the exiled poet
novelist
essayist painter and world traveler
managed to include such a vast range of
perspectives and forms in his texts
that in the process of selecting which
poems to include in footwork
i wanted to offer a survey of his life
as a poet
from his earlier pieces to those he
composed near the end of his life
severe sardui was not known to follow
convention
nor did he think that conventional
approaches to storytelling
or lyrical composition could capture the
complexities of human behavior
or personal and national identity
the publication of his major works
followed the cuban revolution
and the political turmoil that would
ensue with field castro's rise in cuban
dictator
portincio batista's loss of power in
1958
as boom literature galvanized by such
authors as mario
parisiosa julio portaza in colors
fuentes
brought latin america increasing
visibility in the world
literary stage this gay author
and artist son of a railroad worker
redefined latin american approaches to
the writing of literature
from the vantage point of his exile in
france and from many other parts of the
world he visited
after departing his country of birth
born in 1937 in callaway cuba
sergey started writing as a young man
publishing in his teenage years in
various cuban literary magazines between
come away and havana
after pursuing studies in medicine in
cuba's capital
he left the island on a scholarship in
1960
to study art criticism in europe
traveling to madrid and then to paris
aware of castro's efforts to police
homosexuality and re-educate
gay men in work camps called military
units to aid production
the writer would reside for the rest of
his life in paris never to return home
sergey achieved considerable notoriety
before his life was cut short in 1993
due to complications with aids
the author's first novel jesus gestures
was published in 1963 but the book by
which she is most recognized is the only
son in los contantes
published in 1967
an experimental work of fiction that
suzanne jill levine
translated definitely into english as
from cuba with a song in 1972
internationally celebrated for his work
sardui
won france's prestigious midi c prize
for his novel cobra which came out in
1972.
indeed critics have published
extensively on his novels and essays
and continued to write about his poetry
sergey's works contain an often chaotic
convergence of linguistic registers and
characters
whose bodies just in drag tattooed or
scarred
distort reconfigure or explode
in big bang fashion or in little deaths
bourgeois efforts to codify or define
a singular latin american identity in
what ensues
i wish to share a series of poems from
his earliest works
to those he wrote near the end of his
life in doing so
in preparation for my conversation with
professor mcdaniel
i hope to illustrate not only some of
sardoi's masterful
formal renderings but also the
expansiveness
with which he wrote into his works vast
geographies of art
philosophy science desire and
germinations on death and the life of
writing
now i think i will be sharing uh
a visualization of of the poems i would
be reading
just so that everyone can get a sense
not only of
of the language um
that surgery is using but also um
the brilliant ways in which she plays
with form
on the page which is much more difficult
to
convey just by reading these poems out
loud so i'll begin
with a poem called it's from
an earlier chat book titled flamenco
it's his first chat book um that came
out in 1969 but
was republished in insidery's book
called big bang in 1974
and and there are there's a series of
poems in this book
dedicated to different forms of flamenco
lands
so this form of dance that we'll be
reading about here is called
in the white space where shadows are
annulled
light goes gnawing at the borders
folding the colors
destroying the forms in the white space
crossing over from the other side of the
band of light
bursting in without limits without
shadows
sphere yellow rectangle green stains
triangle convergence of the iris pieces
whose marble is hardly visible
or drawn are won over once more by the
light
decomposed expelled from the page
disjointed figure
extinguished that in the white space
an instant later goes insinuating its
forms
creating fringes of color defining their
borders
appearing while the excessive light
withdraws
a head a squared saffron blue and green
ovals
a prism a segmented body white
so i will move forward to another
chat book that um came out originally
in in 1970 uh mood indigo which follows
duke ellington's
uh eponymous uh album called
mood indigo and read a poem within that
book
it's also been published in the re
publication of big bang
but this poem is called echoes of harlem
echoes of harlem black panthers
with shut shutters with planks studying
doors
with bags of sand and broken mirrors and
amulets blocking windows
incantations murder white john janae and
forgotten suitcase
machine guns everything must be broken
echoes of striped harlem cyclone
little hash cakes zero
nina at piano everything must be
destroyed the next time fire
so as we move forward i won't be reading
this poem but just to
offer again another sense of how much
surgery in his earlier works
is playing with form um
i show you here uh home mood indigo
and it's uh it's taking the shape of a
of a spiral and and uh referring to a
number of musical venues
uh and in the history of jazz music
played in different venues
transatlantically
and but i i would like to move on to
the next poem that comes from big bang
um which is uh
essentially about surgery's obsessive
thought about
the theory of the big bang it's as the
creation of the universe but also
as sort of this um
standing this figure standing in for or
um ironic desire for the encounter of
two lovers and
um and and many other things
so much of surgery's celestial
knowledge is encapsulated in
these beautiful poems about celestial
bodies
and heavenly bodies is another term that
could be used
to discuss one of these one of these
ideas
heavenly body the weight of your body
on my body suturing skin ciphered
green saliva on your back spine on spine
knees knotted smeared with
phosphorescent lacquer
the bones light up the black wild room
volumes articulating
entering in silence greased
slowly each and another each
and another radiance descending
over the wall along the distance of the
wall dead asters falling to the sheets
marble
and so this poem concludes uh the
translation of big bang
and and really uh much of surgery's
experimental work with with form but it
doesn't
conclude his brilliant renderings of
new sorts of um
language that goes into very traditional
form and
in a fleeting and masked witness which
came out in 1985
uh we see a series of really beautiful
sonnets heavily
evocative of homoerotic desire
and sex and so one of these uh poems i'd
like to read they're all
untitled um but opening up with
this book is one of these beautiful
sonnets
with the first one called the murmur of
machines was growing
the murmur of machines was growing in
the adjacent room
already my hope for an adjective for
your body was nothing more than an
attempt to shorten the day
the night was arriving and preceding the
desert wind
the certain light or your naked feet on
the mat
of sunset or suspending time
i do not remember love only desire
not the lack of faith only the sphere
the image facing its reflection with
white
texture the true page or your body which
i still reread
fast neogram spring
another example of sergey's obsessive
work
with not only the sonnet form but with
sound as
this subsequent sonnet
not the voice preceded by the echo or
the ravenous reflection of the naked
bodies and the quicksilver
of the quiet crystals with this simple
brush stroke
dry the fruits on the table
in the colonial landscape
when the hour of the siesta was
enveloped
when the hour of the siesta enveloped us
in the density of its self-dwelling seas
or in the murmur of its ended fiesta
when one
and the other extinguished thirst when
light advanced
through the orchard that the flame tree
redden
we opened then the great door to the
insular murmur of noon
and to the timely still life
the final sonnet i'll be reading from
this section
pull out of me more than what was left
out
for when reaching and defining emporia a
planet
on the other side of its day ignites in
the night of its senses
not by force for the human temple of
venus ii
does not take pleasure in being wounded
by the berninian
arrow or by frenzy someday you will lay
lubricants or natural substances between
the borders
with cunning prudence or with salivated
caution
that might ease the burning of your
entrance
because with love and with ardor and the
annals of history
our nuptials are ciphered
nearing the end of surgery's life we see
another
publication of sonnets
which i've translated as the title is a
perennial and betrayed witness
it comes out in 1993 but i'd like to
focus
in this section of the reading for the
conversation
um on surgery's brilliant work with
decimats which
different from the sonnet is an even
more compact
uh form of ten lines
and a very strict rhyme which was not
reproducible
uh in the spanish but um in my work
in in rendering these these decimals
into english i did
do my best to convey the sense of
compactness
and musicality um so the first series of
decimals is
comes from a series of uh a poems called
the crown of fruits
cherry moya who hasn't tried a cherry
moya
in the shade of a red man jack tree
danae waves and weaves and undoes
time and gold and rum sickly sweet and
sugary
for the inexperienced tongue
neither green nor right the palate takes
delight
fruit no pulp of the fruit
pleasure but pleasure standing still
i like to read now uh decima
number four called pineapple
i placed evolved pineapple on these
chinese oranges
and added in the corners the sweetest
guava
in this way in exile the insular queen
crowns baroque are still like
little and death which i've offered her
and the emblem that it evokes there will
be no pain
no more pain or oblivion
finally from the series cashew
however you close the mouth the tasty
cashew
acidic then sweet
turns your palate upside down if you
spill its juice
is a little matter a sudden idol drama
a light fright when it's red hangs
higher
than the hummingbird than fire
so the last uh nasima that i'd like to
read from a different
series of decimals comes from a series
dedicated to
orishas which surgery has dedicated to
jorge and
miguel barnett to the originals in cuba
it's the book written by uh natalia
bolivar
and of course to the cabrera and pierre
version
i will be reading um from this series
the final one
titled piano show
mother of water new moon a dove
a lamb i will offer to the austere sea
that i might
pass this test with life
comes death across a white cascadia
over the yellow forehead you will write
my final breath
and against tide and wind i'll row until
i reached the other shore
following sargeray's death came the
publication in 1999 epis
complete works um and this is one of
the most brilliant poems i think in his
work
um particularly due to what
he does with the form and it as you read
and hear the poem in english
um you'll notice that this poem which is
dedicated to the letters of the alphabet
actually follows the letters of the
alphabet from a to z
each line begins with that letter and
also ends with that other
subsequent uh and a series that follows
each other so
i will read uh this beautiful poem
uh english as well to the letters of the
alphabet
arden's letter your blood will be
ephemera
brief like flowers of the baobab
creating words
that other letters sit drop from
a ruse blunder elsewhere
writing was in another empire fragment
crib not raga and kip
grave thunder of a golden gong hint and
reflection
of an ancient left image that the space
gives of its own
eye joining together letters
sun and hajj kafka finds himself with
his devil
k like a days ago writing of a rumor
that's lethal
yano filled combined in the words of
love
mother may doesn't forget this nor does
islam
nor the monk who taught in the monsoon
or he who wrote with letters and prayed
o vietnam mondrian
paints listening to biba question
who is duchamp and who who reflected in
the trivial and the stellar
signs silences do we not see the shadow
or is there indeed all the being of
light as in rembrandt
universe of letters where you you
painted cities
tel aviv westminster by monet
the grey glasgow tylography of the crude
space
it here is his signature severus arduin
zagging left-handed algorithm of
stubborn blitz
geneva 8 8 88.
so the final problems i'd like to read
come from
a time when sargerie was well aware of
his own
uh imminent passing and in writing
epitaphs
both uh to himself about himself
uh but about his his friends as well um
who are also
dying of aids um
habitats one
here lies death and severe he who used
so many shoes souls whose hips he abused
from the front and from behind laconic
adagio and soothsayer
inscribed on his tomb the skeletal
crumbles
the skeleton crumbles gold of jewels
undone
his name in between two dates the dead
man's out to dance
five death
you are so lazy in delivering your
sentence
here rests your witness it astonishes
and even delights to see you labor
to see you scarce to see your
disappearance with the pleasure of
surrender
your siege of ash pounding the funny
vertebrae
that's your way of being
six savage like the lashing of rags and
future fraction
deaths violent gob of spit there's no
embrace what's faithful
or long term two dates a shroud dry and
brief design
my confession and abomination jewel
colorphone and emblem of the baroque
funeral
six at my funeral
may there be cheese and guava and music
may the mortuary protocols
be abridged and limited no excessive
lamenting
no bach light music
for good taste colors don't lay flowers
on me
if on the highway i die
i realize there's some numbering issues
here in the
in this edition this was six and the
final one
but that ends the uh the
the reading and now i i'll stop sharing
the screen
and uh i welcome conversa
uh conversation and questions about
these poems
the process of translating them and
anything else as well
great thank you so much david uh thank
you i'll just be brief and say thank you
to the organizers of this event thanks
for the invitation
uh to all the sponsors we really
appreciate it and thanks most of all of
course you to the public for being here
via zoom we wish we could celebrate this
in person of course but this is that
we're working with what we got
so it's a real pleasure to be here with
all of you and uh
i'll just get started um i will also
encourage you to submit questions you
have in the chat we'll get to those
we'll be plenty of time for the q a we
have such a good showing here today
which we appreciate and also see a lot
of uh people in the know who work on
side of dewey who have made important
contributions to sauroi scholarship etc
so we look forward to your questions uh
as well um i guess i can just get
started off kind of in a general
sense dave if you could just kind of
tell us a little bit um you know
what what possesses somebody to
translate
uh you you were talking about sort of
this obsession
or this obsession uh obsessive method
that he had with sort of revisiting
you know the sauna and these different
things well i would imagine that that
kind of obsession
probably also falls on the shoulder of a
translator of sardui
as well so if you could maybe just tell
us kind of what what gets you started
uh down this path thank you sean i
i fell in love with sargerie's poems
from the beginning
i i uh you know from the first moment i
encountered them
i found a small edition of poems
also published in the 80s called daikiri
i was a master's program in spanish at
the university of virginia
and naikidi contributed also to the 1985
publication
that i just was reading from and there's
these
brilliantly complex sonnets and i
thought oh these
i i know the sonnet forum i i i love
that
anyway and i thought it would be super
accessible
um when i was you know this is my first
encounter with this poem
and uh and i found very quickly that
that was absolutely not the case
but something about uh his ability
to infuse language with
so many things happening at once um was
really compelling to me
thank you is composed of only eight
sonnets um but they're
all extremely homoerotic and all at the
same time
very subtle in some ways and very
outrageous
and hilarious in other ways so i just
became obsessed
uh from the beginning and and i i i had
to read more
and then but i stayed with the sonnets
initially and then i
i found these other brilliant formal
renderings that i thought would be um
important to share with his work too he
never
stuck with only one form he was
experimenting
throughout his life with uh with how
language could
could convey um some of his central
obsessions but in different ways on the
page and vocally
so i thought this was something that had
to be shared um
primarily because so much emphasis is on
his novels
um but uh there should be greater
attention to his poetry as well
yeah i mean you know it's the this this
formal
you know uh this this aesthetic
experimentalism that defines a lot of
his work
um and the fact that there's so many as
you said this plethora of expressive
modes and registers repertoires that
coexist
and all of his work and you know
thinking about
how meaning is so embedded in the
language itself can you share with us
sort of how you
how you approach these linguistic points
of contact or maybe these dissonances
is probably a better way to frame the
question as opposed to points of context
i think that's something that would be
really interesting people because i know
that's something that was on my mind
when i had heard that you had translated
started i immediately had a bunch of
questions of like
what are the exigencies what are the
logistics of doing so what are the
the high points the low points the
challenges i think if you could walk us
through some of that i think the people
will be really interested in hearing
about that
oh that's a great question i the
dissonances
were wonderful and maddening at the same
time
so uh an example would be the poem
whose first line is pull out of me more
um it's not that it it's not
like that exactly in spanish there's a
there's a pun going on in that first
line that is both
upon beckoning the other
uh towards some sort of physical
encounter
but at the same time uh distance
distancing him or herself from that
other person
um but you you don't see that um
in in the formal writing of the verse uh
alone you have to read the first line
out loud
and you hear within that first line
there's a pun of being articulated
um to
stay away from me um
and also and
there's an invitation to sexual
encounter so this is something i
i had to hear out loud and one of my
first
uh um conversations about this poem was
with
a um a brilliant scholar gustavo pagone
who
i was working with in a translation
workshop
um who i with whom i discussed this
this problem and i think i i spent
way too many years trying to find the
line that um
that would work and finally decided that
there was obviously no perfect line in
the english let's do what
started with this doing um at the same
time
i i in all of my um workings
with the sonnets especially but also the
destinats
um i i tempted at least to
infuse the poems still with um
some sort of english version of the of
the sexual
innuendo but also with rhyme music
etc so that you can get a sense of this
sense of play also in the english
it's it seems like a tall order right uh
i mean it seems like a very
uh not only delicate process a maddening
one
um an obsessive one um but but a tall
one at the same time right so i mean i'm
wondering
you know when i talk about sardui
there's only i always look at this
kind of loop there's always this sort of
circular circularity going on with me
where i'm trying to
kind of talk about all the topics that
he's broaching within a short span
and so i mean how you know considering
this vast array of again repertoires
registers
uh you know that spans or this cosmic
eradication if we think of big bang
or or the whole black hole um but also
at the same time these are very deeply
intimate
realms of the poetic subject you know
can you share your thoughts about
how you navigate kind of the mundane and
the metaphysical at the same time
in his poetry right um but i think that
it takes a long time
with his work to to sort of try to
figure out what
he's doing um so supposed to read
a lot of his poems and read all of them
and get a sense of his
more global obsessions but also to get a
sense of how in each poem he's
he's playing with the reader so if we
were to go back to that same sonnet
pull out of me more i initially became
so obsessed with that first line that i
i neglected to pay attention to the
broader
um philosophical aporia
which is which comes up in the second
line which is pointing to
tension between two distinct
uh ways of viewing the same thing
um it became apparent to me that the
sonic was not only
a very funny sonnet but one but an
invitation
and instructions to the reader to to
go into the poem deep deeply and
and to extract meaning from it um in
from different perspectives and to pull
out of me more
was was what i finally landed on because
i i realized that much of certainly's
poems
were instructions to me as a reader and
as a translator
to to understand this philosophical
dissonance between
um life and death between
being and non-being between physical
encounter and the metaphysical uh
uh sentiment behind desire um
and how at the end of one's life um
which is what you know i think you see
at the sort of like experience of
of orgasm right this big bang or little
little death at the end of the poem
there's this realization
of one's imminence and imminent passing
and that at least if there's a a sense
of
um of encounter between two people
that is that is sealed with the nuptials
of desire
and love that's where once history can
be written
so so i i i don't know if that's a
direct answer to your question
but i but i found in sergey's poems both
maddeningly difficult
complexities but also a deeper
philosophical troubling of of
um of one's existence and the fact that
one's identity
can never be fully defined except
through through dissonance and through
this philosophical
um complications that can never be
resolved um
but but still can be pointed to through
language
and through music um so my work was
really to
find ways to celebrate that language
through sergeant's music and
trying to do that in english definitely
you know i i'm hearing the last thing
you were saying i'm wondering
how much the the title you've selected
for this collection footwork
applies not only this side of the poetry
but your translations
of them as well can you kind of just
talk us through that title a little bit
yeah so i the title is really hard
none of this um none of the individual
titles of his books seemed appropriate
for the full collection of his work
uh of his works and and um
and so many of his sonnets were untitled
so they lacked sort of names to
uh sort of enter into them we just sort
of began reading them
and um and so i i was going back to his
earlier works which i think
have received the least amount of
attention
and um and noticed that there was so
much emphasis
on on dance and and then notice that
this sort of permeated
you know not only the all the many
different references to types of
dance and flamenco
and and
and in other forms of dance but it was
what came out in his final
episode the one who shu's souls
were born thin because there was so much
dancing in his life
so um so i thought why not
something referential to feet to um
to feet that are not only sort of the
few that are dancing but also
uh the the sort of
formal renderings that he was taking up
in so many of his
poems through um through hindi syllabic
verse through
through decimals and and really honor
sort of his work
with the form of the body and with the
feet that create
his mind
wow that's great thank you you know
thanks for sharing those thoughts
and and just you know the idea of of
music or
you know dance the the somatic movements
musicality theatricality all of these
things you know
converge in his work of course but um
you know i'm wondering
sort of one of the most compelling parts
i think has to do with jazz which you
read or you showed us one of the
the formal poems right um and i'm just
wondering you know how are you thinking
moving forward about music in sardui's
poetry i mean particularly with respect
to like the the the poems about harlem
and jazz
and um you know like espira negra is one
of the poems you put up right mood
indigo
i'm just wondering sort of how you read
that larger sort of transnational
um you know uh conversation that's
happening around black aesthetics
and sort of the work that he's done in
his prose for example and in his poetry
as well about afro-cuban culture
you know i'm just kind of wondering how
you read sort of transnationally those
elements in this in his poetry
right and i i really love that question
because there has been some scholarship
on it
but i but i i would love through these
translations to bring greater attention
to sergey's earlier
with obsessive um work
with with music through poetry and also
his attention
given to race um from cuba with the song
is is that is that classic novel that
that those who
study cuban literature will go back to
to talk about
um surgery's own and cuba's origins of
the african slave trade um
and but also uh chinese labor
but also the history of spain in in cuba
on
on the island and and that natal really
does a lot of
good work to point to those concerns
but what surgery is doing in
in mood indigo is is bringing greater
attention to
musical forms as they um
travel from from one geographic location
to another
so what's really interesting about mood
indigo
and and and espiral negra
is is the gaps in knowledge
that you can't see as easily
in in the prose right so he's actually
using the form of the poem to show these
geographic
uh leaps um that music has managed to
transcend uh between different
um musical venues
uh paris new york
um and and then create
at the same time white space around
which
history um and narrative can't be read
uh so so as much as surgery is writing
about the history of musical form he's
also writing about
how that history um
through sort of violent uh eruptions in
form
can never be fully accessed which is
one of the reasons i couldn't really
read it out of reading
you have to appreciate it on the page
definitely yeah and just sort of just
kind of thinking about that do you what
do you know
about sort of sardui's practice of like
reciting the poems that he wrote or what
kind of spaces did they exist in
public private i don't know if you know
have any information or details about
that
that's a great question um there are
some interviews of him online where he
you know he's
he honors the history of sound and music
and
and he was a brilliant he would recite
his
decimals brilliantly um but i but i
actually don't i haven't been able to
find any of his readings
um or and i don't know of of him
you know going to venues and giving like
poetry readings
um if someone in the audience does i
would love to hear about that
um and uh but i think that's a really
great question
um so much of his of his sort of the
criticism on him is dedicated to the
novels but
absolutely yeah yeah absolutely and
going off that as well you know this is
this is another reason why the
intervention you're making is so
important
um is that it it you know brings other
kinds of readings the start of the way
it opens
we up to different kinds of audiences
but there's also something you know
like you said the sort of inevitable
gesture to go back to the pros or the
predominance of the prose
right of his prose versus the poetry and
so i think you know something i was very
interested in learning about because i
know san luis pros much better than i
know his poetry and the same case could
be made about other cuban writers as
well regardless for example
um you know how do you situate stardust
poetry within the landscape of latin
american poetry what are some other
poets that he's sort of engaging with
riffing off of uh or how can you read
him in the context of with respect to
other latin american poets because i see
the formal experimentalism i was
thinking like right like this
anti-poetic kind of practice and i was
just wondering if you kind of
would you would use that paradigm to or
how you would sort of think through his
poetry in a larger
context yeah i love that question
because he does play with forum on the
page
and and so doesn't it but at the same
time
um as you sort of enter into the sonnets
you get a sense of his deeply
embedded devotion to the to the baroque
and to to writers like
but also to uh to
spanish baroque poets like and
and and which is why his sonnets are so
complicated because he's at one time
using this really high register of
rhetoric
where one like
one noun is connected to a verb like in
the next stanza
and and you're supposed to figure out
what the sentence is meaning
syntactically
and at the same time he there's a low
register
pun going on there about a sexual
encounter so
so he is you know obsessed with
uh saint john and lacrosse cross
with many of the spanish baroque poets
but also
um i think is in the in the background
there too but also a peruvian poet uh
um when uh there's a poem about
blows in life um that is so
reminiscent of one of uh cesar vallejo's
famous poem that is also talking about
those of life but when you read it
inside reads poem it's
it's almost you you hear it
but you also hear like kind of a joke
about
about like you know making the blows of
life not really
something to to worry about that much
because it's just
one of those things that happens and
this particular problem i'm thinking
about is
a flawed sexual encounter that just goes
bad and
it's like oh well you know that happens
sometimes
um and you know think about faith on
vedico in a different way now too
[Laughter]
yeah he's thinking of all these writers
and he's also working with the um
really canonical boom writers at the
same time right he
helps bring uh um
a hundred years of solitude into french
so so he's
he's got all of these authors in mind as
he's situating his own
verse and novels on a much more
international
uh landscape
great thank you that that helps because
that's again one of the really exciting
parts about your contribution here is
that
you know it's giving some more um entry
points inside of
his poetry right it's sort of propelling
us even those of us who do read sardui's
prose you know to to maybe uh spend some
more time and attention with his poetry
i have many many more questions that i
could talk to you about but honestly the
chat is blowing up
and i think it'd be really great uh to
give some time to
uh some people's questions so i'll just
i'll i'll pick a few out to get us going
here and think
thank you to all of you for submitting
questions um i don't know if you can see
the chat function david but i'll read
them out loud so everybody can hear it
such incredible work david could you say
a bit about said louie's life in paris
was he influenced by french poets model
etc or maybe in conversation with work
by cezaire or senor
uh oh i love that question he was very
much embedded and
in french culture he his partner
francois was a philosopher
and he uh they were partners very early
on in his time in europe until the end
of
uh series life and so in
his time spent in paris was very much
embedded in
in post-structuralism and deconstruction
he um worked with telkel
and he um he knew giuliana there's a
really cool
photo of him in conversation with
with christeva at a cafe and if you've
seen this
photo you know what i'm talking about
it's like crusaders in the center but
on the side like looking inside to each
direction i think that's sort of like
emblematic of this really interesting
moment in french theory uh in
sort of reason conversation with bar
roland barth at the same time
and in so much of his poetry is you can
see this
influenced by his sort of understanding
that
um of the ways in which language only
can provide a
partial sort of understanding of of
one oneself so yeah he's aware of all
these french
writers that that you that this
questioner is bringing up and but he's
also sort of
writing out the philosophy of
deconstruction in his poems
uh which adds another um really
frustrating complications translating
them and grounding them in the physical
body that comes out
as well well let's let's keep those
frustrations of translation going with
this next question then because
from emma says i highly enjoy to the
letter of the alphabet since your
translation is also
a vegetarian a cedarian what was your
the experience of translating words from
spanish to english
while confined to the same first letter
are there any words you had to replace
or translate them directly
that was so hard but um
it was really fun too and i don't i i
think maybe i
i might have a problem like i i loved
the complication of not
knowing how to make this work but it was
i
sergeant must have had so much fun
writing that poem like just the date
itself eight
eight eight um i don't think he
he might not have written it all on that
same day but
it's there so i enter the text with a
sense of playfulness and devotion
more so you're right to the series of
letters at the beginning of the
of the poem starting each line but also
at the end
um so so if you re when you read it
um again you will notice that there are
some aberrations
um
and at the same time i tried to to sort
of
stick to more so to the forum so that
you could see this this working in
english
um one of the aberrations that you'll
see is i just couldn't
get an o at the end
of the line with the first
word the line begins with an o what is
that
word um here it is
i don't remember but but the last line
you'll see
the last word is not the letter o
it's the word so or he wrote
or he who wrote with letters and prayed
oh
so if you can think of a word that like
ends with o
and would make sense in that line um
give me a call and we'll talk about it
that would be really fun to think of
another way of translating the poem but
it was really hard to make sense of that
line
the word that ended in o so i just
thought of the action of praying
um rather than trying to end the line
with oh i
did sort of like a homophonic joke to
to the sound oh might say when
praying um so that's one of the
aberrations that's there but you're
right to
point that out also in the english
language there's no
like double l letter but i couldn't
extract that from on either so it was
kind of freeing in a way
to to add another letter to the english
alphabet
i love hearing about the methodology of
translating in these
these uh um next question is coming from
andy alfonso somebody who has a thing or
two about star gui
um also aside from the experimental
poetry that we've been talking about are
there more political poems that directly
reference or allude to the context of
the revolution that saudi somewhat
escaped
and that you briefly described in your
intro to the talk
um that is a really great question
i i'm thinking back to
a poem that he didn't read but
um but it's called havana
sextet and it's a poem in six
parts and it's really
sort of like this nostalgic piece
about asking where did all of these
thing
things that were part of a previous cuba
go
and um and there's a there are
many cultural references in the poem
that you just kind of have to know
and that um that that you if you don't
know them
it it makes the poem so um
initially less uh penetrable
but one of the references is to a
trapeze artist called chakumbele
and who tragically
fell from
from he's walking across this tightrope
and he um this is a real a real guy and
he's
he looks down at well so the myth goes
he looks down at this beautiful woman
who he's in love with
and he sees her kiss someone else and so
he
he's distracted and he falls and his
body's maimed
and and he can never participate in this
brilliant art of which he's so
good again he becomes you know like a
policeman
and so i i had no idea what this word
was
um at all until i just like i had to go
i had to google it
and um i wrote uh
roberto do you know anything about this
cultural reference and then um he sent
me
uh a cuban radio show
about about charcoal belly and the myth
that he that his name encapsulates and
so
just that one word
sent me down like a rabbit hole of just
being obsessed with what
sergey's lines and his earlier poems
were doing and i think he really was
thinking at the time how can i
think of right about this place um
that is just no longer the same and sort
of honor
um the musicality of
of cuba and and um you know these open
fairs
of circuses and uh
and and dances and all of these things
and sort of
ask where they've gone in the end
so yeah i i don't know if it's a direct
political reference but it's a um
but it's in this it's a nostalgia and
viewed poem about what has been lost
from
the history of cuba great
thank you thank you for your question
thanks for your your answer david
i'm gonna go to um alexandra next uh
they say i noticed that louise frequent
use of specific colors in his poems
i was also thinking something similar
the function of nouns right um
there was a lot of bit a lot has been
written about the word plumas
right so i'm just wondering sort of what
along with alexander's question here
what kind of weight do these
nouns that perhaps reappear or presences
like you know
i'm just worried how that kind of
figures into your process or that
you know how you read that inside
louie's work but for alexander's
specific question
i know this sad really frequent use of
specific colors in his poems especially
the color white he seemed to like white
for specific foods
to what do you attribute his use of
particularly strong colors for example
in his blank pages poems
um alexander that's a great question
you probably know this but uh sergey was
also a painter and he was
obsessed with color i believe there's
one um
line in an interview of his that where
he says colors
cure and he was obsessed with sort of
the meaning
behind color and um and
which brought him also to his obsessive
uh
mystical um thinking about
the work of rothko's paintings and so so
that was
very much um part of his part of his
life too he's a
really i think a brilliant painter and
you can find his works
um in the princeton firestone uh
archives uh and go see them um
and they're beautiful um so so
not only was he writing about color that
he was painting these these formal
works that were often obsessed with
circles um
and in squares and ellipses and
rectangles
and uh there's a lot you can say about
this but one of them
one of the things that you can say is
related to white space and black space
so um if you see in the sort of
like this the the black spiral um
there's there so he's obsessed with the
sense of negative space
uh of impenetrability but also of death
so i i believe some
criticism by again roberto gonzalez
points to the fact that and um
in yoruba white means death so there's
this
there's a sense of of
history being imbued by
by the presence of death and in black
spiral and
food indico but um if you
if you look at other uh poems you'll
also see sort of like
a celebration of orange
of red thinking i've gotten back to a
sonnet about rothko
um and and uh some other colors too
many of the poems are about still lights
right um either directly or indirectly
so he's
painting the life of a figure
um in a sonic while it's
um also just still there so what's
beautiful about the translation of
english of spanish to english is that
becomes in english a still life
so the two poems juxtaposed to each
other
are recognized um this
the presence of death but also the
continuance of life
through the preservation of color and in
paintings and then and
in sonnets
great thank you thanks for the question
thanks for sharing your thoughts
the next one i'll go to is from um
shivangi really great question while
translating did your life world and your
own positionality impose or interfere in
the way you interpreted
and translated his work and i think we
can kind of piggyback off that question
too to just think about larger
methodologies of translation i think you
you know what is it about your own
uh you know uh story history that kind
of
a perhaps drew you to sardui and how do
how does how does your your own
perspective sort of figure into the ways
in which you translate that
yeah i think that's a really important
um
and ethical question right that i have
to
um consider when i'm when i'm thinking
of
of how to render someone else's work
into another
into english and so i think that's
that's really
central and in their work of translation
and it's one of the questions that comes
up in a
i'm i'm teaching a translation course
this term
um but so yes i i think it
it sort of um
necessarily does restrict
my ability to perfectly translate
a piece of work in the way that it was
written
in the in the original language so i
think
um yeah for one i i
i came to his works in a very sort of
um i guess economical training right i
was reading about his works
uh through through the canon um and as i
was getting my
master's degree in spanish at the
university of fijian at the university
of virginia so
immediately you know i my understanding
of the works were
was sort of historicized and
understanding
him already with a large amount of
criticism
behind him but also i you know i
i um was trying to
place his works in conversation with
with
with lots of texts that i didn't know
existed
as in conversation with those poems so i
think
both my education and my lack of sort of
contemporary of the the moments in which
she was publishing the works
from paris um not really
from a university system but through you
know in
in journals and these really um
in these publications that had really
small prints
um i wasn't reading them in the ways in
which they were initially published so i
felt sort of
constricted by that and um
and uh and i'm not cuban so i i felt
limited
by initially by my understanding
sometimes of cuban idiom so i
shared poems with with others who might
like
have a different perspective because i
wanted to balance
um my limitations with sort of the
perspectives
and backgrounds and readerships of
others who might have different
um who might hear things differently
as as i initially did when i was reading
that first sonnet but i
discussed um i'm sure i'll find
um even more uh um
really fruitful conversations about the
ways in which sergey's poems
can and should be read differently and
translated differently and i think
that's what surgery would have wondered
as well
yeah and i think you know what's really
useful about what you're sharing is you
know it goes against the idea of
translating between languages is like a
dialectical process
right it's really rather a lot comes to
bear right and i think in the case of
san luis poetry
you know you you you are already
counting on excellent translators of
saturday's pros to be able to engage
with
and a larger obviously um a community of
scholars
of san diego's work as well right so
it's very interesting how all of those
kind of points of contact have to be
marshaled
or deployed to be able to uh you know
approximate these translations
yeah um i'm going to go to adrian adams
thank you for your question
um could you speak more about how
strategy's aids-related deaths shaped
the posthumous circulation of his work
within both cuba and international
circles
which circles took up and or disregarded
certain elements of his repertoire
wow that's a great question
um i think when i think about that
question
the first text that comes to mind is
which came out soon after his death in
1993
um beach birds and it was translated by
susan joe levine
and i believe also pearl meyer um
and in that that text is really very
much about
um it's it's about an unnamed island
and on which uh
young men are dying premature like
an unnamed disease and and it's a
beautiful book it's
much more i would say the pros is much
more um
i don't know accessible in a sense
compared to his earlier words
uh but incredibly haunting
at the same time and it's impossible not
to think of
of aids and also cuba um and so i
i when i think of that question i think
very much
about how surgery was
conscious of the fact that he was about
to die
um many of his writer friends had
already died when when we had died
um and
and he was trying to write the story
of of this imminent passing that had no
resolution
uh and i and i really i i view this
novel as
as a beautiful rendering of that
inevitability
and also um
a tragic sort of telling of
how he viewed his own
departure from the world and as a writer
so i see that very much embedded in the
novel
but also as you can see in the epitaph
i i think they deserve a lot more
attention because
it's obvious that he's that he's um
talking about
he's writing into the epitaphs with the
word um
in spanish uh his own name and it's sort
of like
honoring the the fact that his name will
be written into
um poems about is about someone's
passing someone who's um who happens to
be
severe uh and will be recognized through
that and
and at the same time in a very sort of
like
in a in a fun celebratory way right he's
he's off to dance
at the end of that poem so so yeah
that's how i see them i
i wish the epitaphs were more red and
more circulated but
maybe this will do some of that work
great thank you thank you everybody for
your your question
uh david i guess just kind of uh before
we you know
wrap things up is there is there
something you'd like to share with us
about you know
what would you like us to know about
sarah louie's poetry or the poet what
should we leave here with
or some some things that delight you
perhaps i mean i think that's something
that came through in your translation
and the ways which you framed it was
sort of
you know not just the severe uh aspects
of his poetry but rather this
this uh wit and humor and irony that was
just
you know incredible i guess any final
thoughts you'd like to share with us
about uh
what we should be thinking going forward
then when we uh all buy your book and
read it of course
um i i love that question
i think of sergey as a
as a playful um brilliant
um poet and i and going forward i
if you can take one thing with you is to
sort of
remember him not only as a as a novelist
but as someone whose
musicality is love of jokes
his love of dance his love of food and
pleasure can be
can be experienced through through song
and so
if if you can honor him in one way is to
to just to enjoy his the music of his
poetry
in spanish or in english and to um take
part in this process of constant
deferral
of meaning i will not let you know
exactly what this poem
is going to mean but you can take more
out of it the more you read it
the more you um participate in the act
of reading
and reading out loud on his poems
and celebrating his music the more the
more he will be
the nuptials of his own desire to write
and to love and to
and to sing will be will be remembered
so
to celebrate his poetry and and take
that with you
that's beautiful what what a beautiful
tribute um as is your book and so
um congratulations again if the public
could please join me in
uh applauding david's book
congratulations
uh we really enjoyed i know i did i know
we all did this very wide-ranging
discussion on a very
complex and important uh writer
anomalous poet uh
and so we just like to remind everybody
that if you know people that would be
interested in this event and weren't
able to attend this will be put up
um on uh the our youtube page i believe
that link was sent out to everybody just
a moment ago in the chat
uh so please uh spread the word pass it
along and it'll be uh made available
soon and so with that i would just like
to thank everybody for attending thank
you david
the organizers everybody who helped get
the setup up and running running so
smoothly there's the link again in the
chat thank you very much from the ritm
and yeah everybody take care and
congratulations again uh to david for
for the book and for sharing his
thoughts on starter buoy with us thank
you sean thank you